[Musique]
le chant de l'Allemagne résonne dans le
lycée franco-allemande Buc instant
solennel pour les mille élèves venus
célébrer les 60 ans du traité de
l'Elysée accord signé entre le général
de Gaulle et le chancelier Adena World
le 22 janvier 1963 objectif sceller la
réconciliation entre la France et
l'Allemagne après plusieurs décennies de
conflits
nous avons été créés en tant que lycée
franco-allemand grâce à ce traité de
l'Élysée et ce qui nous semble très
important en tant qu'acteur du
franco-allemand c'est effectivement que
les dirigeants des deux pays fassent
vivre au quotidien ces échanges et ce
lien d'amitié ça fait 60 ans donc c'est
quelque chose qui dure surtout que la
France est l'Allemagne ça quand même une
histoire assez compliqué et que nous en
tant que jeune on soit aussi là pour se
remémorer ça ce mardi 17 janvier des
animations réalisées par les élèves du
CP jusqu'en terminal était proposé
concert joué par les ensembles musicaux
de l'école mais aussi analyse de Audi
sur les couples présidents chanceliers
on a dû décrire et savoir enfin un peu
imaginer grâce à nos connaissances
notamment savoir
quelles étapes de l'histoire se passait
était représenté sur ses caricatures ils
sont je crois au lycée franco-allemand
de Buc extrêmement conscient aussi de
leur mission et de la nécessité de
continuer le travail et de rapprocher
les peuples les uns des autres cette
semaine de commémoration se conclura ce
dimanche pour 40 élèves de terminale du
lycée franco-allemand de Buc ils seront
conviés à la Sorbonne à Paris pour la
célébration du traité avec Emmanuel
Macron et le chancelier olapials